some breaking news here at sky center
and
we've learned this morning that peter
lorimer
leads united all-time leading goal
scorer has died
at the age of 74. leeds
have tweeted this morning to say it is
with great
sadness that the leads have learned of
the passing of club legend peter lorimer
at the age of 74 following a long-term
illness i can tell you that he made 705
appearances and scored
238 goals over two spells with the club
and the age of
15 years and 289 days specifically he
made his debut against southampton in
1962 and remains to this day
the youngest ever player to play for
leads we have heard some words from the
lead ceo
angus kinnear today he says is an
incredibly sad day for leeds united
peter lorimer
epitomized the word legend not only was
he our record goal scorer
from a decorated era of our history but
he continued to work
closely with the club until it was no
longer possible
in recent months our thoughts the
statement goes on are with sue
and all his family he will be missed
greatly
so the death has been announced this
morning of as you've heard there the
leeds legend peter lorimer at the age of
74 following a long-term illness